[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich bin ja gerade voll im Putzfimmel
und möchte einfach das Haus auf Vordermann bringen.
Frühjahrsputz ist angesagt.
In diesem Video zeige ich euch, wie ihr schnell und einfach
euer Badezimmer sauber bekommt,
ein paar Tipps und Tricks zur Abflussreinigung
und natürlich auch Tipps und Tricks
zur Reinigerselberherstellung.
Sagt man das so?
Ich glaube schon.
Denn ihr braucht wirklich nicht viele Reiniger zu Hause.
Ihr braucht wirklich nur einen ganz, ganz kleinen Schrank,
einen kleinen Vorrat,
und könnt euch so viel Geld sparen,
viel Zeit sparen
und viel Platz sparen.
Los geht es jetzt bei mir.
Denn ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal
die Schränke innen ausräumen, ausmisten.
Und da gibt es auch den ganz einfachen Trick:
Lagert einfach nicht zu viel,
verbraucht eure Produkte auf, bevor ihr neue aufmacht.
Das gilt gerade bei Shampoo, bei Cremes,
dass ihr einfach nicht so viel rumstehen habt im Badezimmer.
Und kauft wirklich nur Sachen, die ihr braucht
und die ihr verwendet.
Also ich fange jetzt hier an.
Wir sind hier bei uns im Elternbad,
also Murats und mein Badezimmer.
Die Kinder haben ein eigenes.
Aber die haben eigentlich kaum noch Sachen,
die sie brauchen.
Die sind ja erst neun und vier.
Von daher haben die gerade ein bisschen Körperpflege
und das war es.
Und ich starte jetzt hier vorne
und dann eben am Waschbecken.
Ausräumen, ausmisten, auswaschen.
Ich benutze jetzt dafür meinen Allzweckreiniger.
Den habe ich selber hergestellt.
Das findet ihr auch in einem anderen Video, das Rezept.
Supereinfach und vor allem
ganz natürlich
und eben
trotzdem stark genug, um alles sauber und rein zu bekommen.
Ich fange jetzt hier bei mir von oben nach unten an,
also erst mal hier diesen Schrank.
Den nutze eigentlich größtenteils ich.
Also der Murat hat hier kaum was drin.
Und ich habe hier natürlich auch Dinge,
die im Alltag so liegenbleiben, anfallen.
Die räume ich dann halt weg.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich eine Box.
Da lagere ich jetzt alles, was ich aussortiere,
was nicht hier ins Bad gehört,
aber was nicht weggeschmissen wird.
Das sortiere ich dann später woanders ein.
Zum Beispiel so alte Kosmetiktüten,
die benutze ich dann, wenn ich was weiterverschenke.
Und hier habe ich aber auch noch an meinem Putz-Caddy
eine Mülltüte für Dinge, die eben sofort entsorgt werden,
also leere Schachteln
– ich glaube, beim Murat werde ich dort ziemlich fündig –
und einfach Dinge, die man nicht mehr so braucht.
Hier bei mir seht ihr zum Beispiel,
ich habe immer nur ein Parfüm,
was ich aktuell benutze,
und habe deswegen auch nur eine Parfümflasche rumstehen.
Ich zeige euch gleich bei Murat das Gegenteil.
Murat hat nämlich immer Tausende Sachen rumstehen.
Aber ich finde, wenn man eben nur eins benutzt
und ich bin eher so der Typ, ein Duft,
der mir eben steht und der zu mir passt,
und alles andere...
Ich habe natürlich auch Parfüm im Vorrat.
Das habe ich dann bei uns in der Vorratskammer.
Wenn ihr aber alles im Badezimmer lagern müsst,
weil ihr eben keine Vorratskammer habt,
dann würde ich einfach nicht zu viel kaufen auf Vorrat.
Also habt wirklich immer nur ein, zwei da.
Das könnt ihr dann hintendran lagern,
die Dinge, die im Vorrat sind,
die Offenen weiter vorne.
Und dann steht das Bad eben nicht so voll
und ihr habt es eben auch schön sauber.
[Musik]
Hier meine Kosmetikpinsel,
die kann ich auch gleich auswaschen.
Die nehme ich schon mal raus,
zumindest die, die ich gebraucht habe.
Denn ich reinige die in wirklich regelmäßigen Abständen.
Ich zeige euch auch gleich wie.
Alle anderen sind noch frisch.
Und hier räume ich dann auch immer mal wieder
alles schön raus,
kann hier mein Werkzeugrondell auch sauber machen.
Denn das wird auch ziemlich schmutzig innen.
Da nehme ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen Wasser
und reibe es aber dann schön trocken.
[Musik]
Und hier habe ich alles so nach Kategorie sortiert,
also Concealer mit Concealerpinsel
und alles in der Reihenfolge,
wie ich es eben auch beim Schminken dann brauche.
Hier habe ich meine Pinsel
und die reinige ich dann immer so:
Ich habe hier im Handwaschmittel
einfach eine pH-hautneutrale Seife.
Damit kann ich mir auch mein Gesicht reinigen.
Da nehme ich einfach ein bisschen was in die Hand
und kreise den Pinsel in der Hand
wie, als würde ich Farbe aufnehmen,
wie bei einer Wasserfarbe,
so ein Wasserfarbkasten.
Ein bisschen Wasser dran.
Und das ist jetzt zum Beispiel mein Concealerpinsel.
Da ist jetzt ein bisschen mehr Farbe drin.
Das muss ich dann zweimal ungefähr machen.
Zwischendurch mal auswaschen.
Und wenn ihr mal wirklich Farbe habt,
die nicht rausgehen will,
gibt es auch spezielle Pinselreiniger.
Den habe ich jetzt einfach beim dm geholt.
Damit sprühst du sie ein.
Geht auch mal kurz so zwischendurch
für die schnelle Pinselreinigung.
Und damit kriege ich dann immer so alle Reste noch raus.
Dann nehme ich mir ein Handtuch
und lasse die Pinsel schön im Liegen trocknen,
damit das Wasser nicht hier unten in den Stiel reinfließt.
Am besten wäre es sogar, so zu trocknen,
wenn ihr so einen Pinselaufhänger habt.
Ansonsten einfach im Liegen trocknen.
[Musik]
Die Pinsel lasse ich jetzt einfach 24 Stunden trocknen
und räume sie dann später dazu.
So. Jetzt kann ich hier auch wieder alles reinräumen.
Mein Parfüm.
Und hier habe ich einfach nur noch mein Haarspray.
Und die Dose, das ist eigentlich eine Dose für unterwegs,
die räume ich, glaube ich,
zu meinen Kleidern,
zu meinen Reisetaschen.
Weil da kommt dann immer Schmuck rein,
wenn ich unterwegs bin,
und dann habe ich es praktisch verpackt.
Ja.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Regal Nummer eins ist fertig.
Jetzt geht es direkt unten drunter weiter.
Und hier arbeite ich einfach mit so einem Boxsystem.
Also ich habe hier ganz viele Regale.
Das Regal haben wir einfach selber gebaut
mit dem Alex zusammen.
Und ich habe ziemlich flache Regale,
sodass ich wirklich immer gut dran komme.
So ist alles immer schön ordentlich.
Ich habe hier oben zum Beispiel den Föhn drin
und Glätteisen
und kann jetzt auch alles ganz einfach auswischen.
[Musik]
Guckt. Und wenn ihr solche Boxen habt,
dann geht alles superschnell.
Und es ist alles ordentlich.
Hier kann ich jetzt gleich die Tür innen und außen auswischen
und abwischen.
Und dann ist der Schrank fertig.
Und das hat jetzt hier keine zehn Minuten gedauert.
Dann geht es jetzt hier unten weiter mit meinem Schrank.
Da ist im Prinzip alles ganz gut sortiert,
weil ich hier auch echt immer eine gute Ordnung halte.
Ich habe hier auch viele Kisten,
die ich dann eben einfach rausnehmen kann,
und kann jetzt hier aber
noch mal über alle Produkte drübergucken.
Wobei ich das echt immer regelmäßig mache.
Also, wenn ich hier abends Zähne putze und morgens,
dann gucke ich immer:
Was brauche ich? Was brauche ich nicht?
Und ich habe echt nur wichtige Sachen bei mir drin.
Und alles andere kann eigentlich weg
oder in den Vorratsschrank.
Gut, hier habe ich so eine
Box für Dinge, die ich gerade nicht sofort wegräumen will,
Schmuck zum Beispiel
oder mal einen Lippenstift
oder eine Halskette
und Dinge, die ich einfach öfter trage.
Das ist halt ein kleines Durcheinander.
Aber das kann ich jetzt auch kurz wegsortieren.
[Musik]
Das hier sind übrigens so Organizer.
Die gibt es in jeder Drogerie
also in verschiedenen Größen.
Und da habe ich mir einfach mal angeguckt,
was ich so brauchen könnte.
Ist noch nicht optimal.
Vielleicht finde ich auch mal einen Organizer,
der noch besser zu mir passt,
zu meinen Lippenstiften.
Aber ja, momentan tut es seinen Zweck.
Da ist immer alles drin, was ich so für jeden Tag brauche.
Also ich brauche nicht jeden Tag so viele Lippenstifte.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, oder?
Weißt du, was ich meine, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
So. Blitzeblank wieder.
[Musik]
Hier mache ich jetzt meine Haarprodukte rein,
die ich übrigens auch nicht mehr alle brauche.
Ich sehe da das hier.
Das kommt jetzt in meinen Vorrat.
Ja.
Mein Gesichtserfrischer.
Ha, jetzt bin ich wieder ganz frisch.
>> JOSH: Das ist Wasser in einer Sprühflasche?
>> SALLY: Ja. Es ist wahrscheinlich
nur Wasser in der Sprühflasche.
A refresher.
Aber da ist bestimmt so ein bisschen Hyaluron und so drin
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: und irgendwas, was deine Haut erfrischt.
>> JOSH: Ein bisschen Aloe Vera.
>> SALLY: Aloe Vera.
Dinge, die Frauen eben brauchen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und hier habe ich so kleine Boxen
für
Haargummis und Haarspangen.
[Musik]
Es sammelt sich doch mehr Dreck an, als man glaubt.
Hier habe ich jetzt noch so meine Haarspangen drin,
meine Riesenhaargummis,
Kamm und Bürste.
Das war es.
So.
Mein Schrank ist aufgeräumt.
[Musik]
Ich zeige euch jetzt etwas.
Aber der nachfolgende Ausschnitt,
die nächsten zehn Sekunden
könnten euch wirklich
schaden.
Ich übernehme keine Haftung.
Murats Schublade.
Das meine ich übrigens mit:
Habt lieber immer nur eins von jedem Produkt da
und nicht so viele angefangene Produkte.
Denn
man verliert dann schnell mal den Überblick.
Der Murat sammelt übrigens auch diese Hotel-
Teile,
die es dort dann als Geschenk gibt.
Die nimmt er dann immer mit, der Schwabe.
Ist ja auch ganz praktisch.
Ist ja ganz gut.
Die kriegt man ja da geschenkt.
Aber die kann man zum Beispiel
in eine Reiseschublade machen.
Ich habe nämlich bei mir im Hauswirtschaftsraum
einfach so eine Reiseschublade,
wo ich die kleinen Teile drin habe.
Und ansonsten sehe ich beim Murat einfach
drei verschiedene Deos,
Kolonya, also Desinfektionsmittel für die Hände,
ganz viele Rasierer,
ganz viele Rasierklingen.
Das darf der gute Mann selber ausräumen. Ja.
Das befreit ihn nämlich.
Das macht ihn dann glücklich,
wenn er das selber macht.
Okay.
Mit meinen Schränken bin ich jetzt also fertig.
Ich habe da drüben noch eine kleine Kiste.
Das mache ich gleich.
Da sind so unsere Badewannenzusätze und so drin.
Jetzt gehe ich als Nächstes direkt mal zum Abfluss,
also Dusche,
und zeige euch da, wie ich den Abfluss vorbereite,
wie ihr ihn einwirken lassen könnt,
damit, wenn er verstopft ist, eben schön frei wird.
[Musik]
Jetzt geht es um eure Abflüsse.
Ihr braucht keine teuren Rohrreiniger oder Abflussreiniger,
sondern wirklich nur zwei Zutaten.
Das ist zum einen die Zitronensäure
und Natron.
Das könnt ihr euch wirklich in großen Packs bestellen.
Das ist ganz günstig.
Einfach im Haushalt lagern.
Und ihr verzichtet wirklich komplett
auf die ganze Chemiekeule, die es überall zu kaufen gibt.
Ihr könnt damit die Dusche reinigen,
also hier den Abfluss,
Waschbeckenabfluss.
Überall, wo was verstopft ist und nicht sauber ist,
könnt ihr wirklich super damit reinigen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier erst mal die Abdeckungen weg.
Die sollte man auch regelmäßig säubern.
Wir machen das hier alle zwei Wochen sauber,
weil gerade bei so großen Duschen bei diesem Abfluss
bleibt halt echt gerne hier mal was hängen.
Und das solltet ihr auch machen.
Ansonsten riecht es, es bilden sich Bakterien,
es kann sich Schimmel bilden.
Und daher wirklich, wirklich gut aufpassen!
Jetzt in gleichen Teilen Natron und Zitronensäure reingeben.
Ich mache jetzt mal so vier Esslöffel.
Die Zitronensäure direkt hinterher.
Man hört auch schon, wie es reagiert.
Und hier jetzt noch direkt heißes Wasser dazu geben.
Nicht zu viel, es soll ja nicht gleich weggespült werden,
sondern einfach nur miteinander reagieren.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt hier auch gerne Essig verwenden statt Zitronensäure.
Allerdings ist Zitronensäure ein bisschen besser.
Denn, wenn ihr da Dichtungen habt,
Gummi oder auch Kunststoffteile,
dann greift Essig diese Teile gerne mal an.
Zitronensäure ist zum einen geruchsneutraler
und einfach ein bisschen
schonender zu Gummi und Kunststoffteilen.
Deswegen habe ich die zwei immer da
und lasse es jetzt hier noch kurz einwirken
und mache solange an einer anderen Stelle weiter.
Als Nächstes ist die Toilette dran.
Die Toilette wird bei uns jeden Tag geputzt.
Das mache ich einfach im Alltag.
Wenn ich morgens auf die Toilette gehe,
dann nehme ich sofort mein Desinfektionsmittel,
mache die Toilette sauber.
Und das, finde ich, gehört auch zum täglichen,
also zum Alltag mit dazu.
Was ich dann noch einmal die Woche mache,
ist, innen drin die Toilette putzen.
Das mache ich jetzt hier mal.
Und bei uns gibt es Cola eigentlich nie zum Trinken,
sondern eher nur zum Putzen.
Wenn ihr also eine Flasche Cola übrig habt,
könnt ihr hier drinnen die Toilette
immer ganz gut reinigen.
Cola löst zum einen Kalk,
Cola löst aber auch Rost, Urinstein und alles.
Ich muss halt sagen, unsere Toiletten
sehen eigentlich nie so schmutzig aus,
weil wir sie wirklich jede Woche
grundreinigen hier innen drin.
Und dann nehme ich jetzt hier
etwas Cola und Natron.
Denn beides reagiert auch ganz gut.
Und ich stelle auch gleich
immer unsere Bürste mit rein.
Da haben wir eine Silikonbürste,
weil
alles andere ich irgendwie ziemlich unhygienisch finde.
Die kriegt man noch schön sauber,
kann sie auch immer schön jeden Tag desinfizieren.
Und das zeige ich euch jetzt hier mal.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr euch selber
einen Toilettenreiniger machen wollt,
mit dem ihr auch wirklich Urinstein,
Kalk und Ablagerungen lösen könnt,
dann braucht ihr im Prinzip nur ein Gefäß,
wieder Natron und Zitronensäure
und etwas Orangenöl.
Das Orangenöl ist
rein aus Orangenschalen hergestellt.
Das ist mein Backöl.
Ich habe jetzt einfach immer eins im Reinigerschrank
und eins im Backschrank.
Und das nehme ich dann einfach für den schönen Duft.
Ihr nehmt jetzt hier Natron und Zitronensäure eins zu eins.
Könnt ihr euch schön auf Vorrat herstellen
und drauf schreiben,
dass es der WC-Reiniger ist.
[Musik]
Hier jetzt schon das Orangenöl mit reingeben.
Man kann hier das Pulver jetzt im Prinzip
auch leicht mit Wasser benebeln
und dann in Eiswürfelformen reindrücken,
trockenen lassen.
Dann habt ihr Spültabs also für das WC.
Aber ich lasse es gerne im Glas.
Ich kann es so einfacher dosieren,
mal mehr oder mal weniger nehmen
je nach Bedarf.
Und das ist wirklich auch ein richtig toller Reiniger.
Ich zeige euch hier den Toilettenreiniger mal.
Ihr nehmt jetzt einfach heißes, kochendes Wasser.
Das kommt in die Toilette
und dann vom Pulver einfach hinterher.
[Musik]
Und dann geht es jetzt im Prinzip
mit meiner Toilettenreinigung weiter wie jeden Tag.
Entweder nehme ich einen Allzweckreiniger
oder einfach Desinfektionsmittel,
sprühe alles schön ein
und ich nehme dann immer Toilettenpapier dafür.
Denn das kann ich dann einfach wegschmeißen
und habe keine Tücher, die dann noch weitere
Bakterien hier in der Gegend herumstreuen.
Zuerst immer hier oben.
[Musik]
Ich muss ja auch dazu sagen,
dass wir beim täglichen Toilettengang
nicht so viel Toilettenpapier benutzen müssen.
Denn wir haben Dusch-WCs.
Hier unten kommt dann so ein Strahl Wasser raus,
der dann
Popo und andere Gliedteile sauber macht.
Und
es ist mir auch wichtig, das zu erwähnen. Denn
gerade bei Kindern, Erwachsenen,
da muss man halt mit Wasser sauber machen,
gerade nach dem großen Geschäft.
So, wie Sarah gestern gesagt hat,
wenn man irgendwie mal hier Hundekacke hat
oder von einem Vogel irgendwie angeschissen wurde,
macht man es sich ja auch nicht
einfach mit einem Tuch weg,
macht man ja auch mit Wasser weg und wäscht es weg.
Und dafür brauchen wir eben beim täglichen
Toilettengang nicht so viel Klopapier,
aber dafür benutze ich halt Klopapier,
um die Toilette sauber zu machen.
Ja. Also jetzt nicht denken,
dass wir hier voll die Klopapierverbraucher sind.
Bei uns gleicht es sich dann wieder aus.
Jetzt gehen wir Richtung Dusche.
Wir haben bei der Dusche immer
ziemlich wenig Kalkablagerungen.
Denn wir haben eine BWT Anlage,
also eine Entkalkungsanlage.
Finde ich auch ganz praktisch,
weil man wirklich weniger putzen muss.
Was wir auch nicht haben, ist eine Glasdusche.
Die hatten wir nämlich in der alten Wohnung.
Und da war es halt echt immer so,
da haben wir jeden Tag, wenn wir geduscht haben,
immer das Glas abgezogen,
damit es eben auch nicht schnell verkalkt.
Aber natürlich muss man trotzdem
die Armaturen immer wieder sauber machen.
Und bei der täglichen Dusche
nehme ich auch einfach mein Handtuch
oder ein Tuch, was eben gerade da ist,
und trockne dann alles ab.
Das habe ich jetzt heute morgen nicht gemacht,
weil ich wusste,
ich werde jetzt heute hier putzen.
Hier bei den Duschköpfen, wenn die ganz stark verkalkt sind,
könnt ihr hier auch Zitronensäure wieder verwenden,
weil Zitronensäure den Kalk löst.
Bei neueren Duschköpfen ist es sogar so,
die haben hier diese Gummilippen
und da kann man einfach, wenn sie trocken sind,
mit dem Finger drüber
und der Kalk löst sich dann von alleine ab.
Natürlich muss man hier jetzt trotzdem
– man sieht es auch ganz gut –
noch mit Zitronensäure und Wasser drübergehen.
Da werde ich jetzt kurz noch mal
ein bisschen Wasser erwärmen, mit Zitronensäure mischen
und hier schön alles abreiben.
Das Ganze mache ich dann auch hier
an den Wänden,
damit wirklich der ganze Kalk runtergewaschen wird.
Und, weil wir einen Dampfreiniger haben,
nehme ich auch oft den Dampfreiniger,
gerade hier auch beim Abfluss.
Den kann ich jetzt übrigens
mittlerweile auch schön sauber machen.
Und dann ist die Dusche im Prinzip auch erledigt.
Also einfach nur Zitronensäure
und das war es.
[Musik]
So leichte Verschmutzungen und Verkalkungen
lösen sich so echt wirklich super.
Und wenn es doch nicht weggeht,
weil es schon länger verkalkt ist,
gebt ihr einfach noch ein bisschen Zitronensäure drauf,
lasst es einwirken
und dann lässt es sich auch gut wegwischen.
[Musik]
Hier ist jetzt erst mal alles sauber.
Der Schwamm hat ausgedient.
Den entsorge ich jetzt.
Und jetzt hole ich einfach nur einen Wischmop
und kann noch mal mit Zitronensäurewasser
hier die Fliesen sauber machen.
Könnt ihr machen, wenn sie sehr verkalkt sind.
Ich mache es mir jetzt ein bisschen einfacher
und nehme den Dampfreiniger.
Mit dem Dampfreiniger komme ich auch hier an Stellen dran,
die ich jetzt mit dem Schwamm nicht so erreiche.
Und das mache ich halt auch regelmäßig,
weil ich so alle Ecken und Kanten noch ausputzen kann
und kann hier sogar noch in den Abfluss reindampfen.
Und dann ist auch alles bakterienfrei.
Denn der Dampfreiniger tötet durch den heißen Dampf
eben auch 99,99% aller Bakterien.
Und dann ist alles wieder sauber und rein.
[Musik]
So.
Jetzt sind alle Wandfliesen geputzt.
Jetzt geht es noch an die restlichen Oberflächen,
das heißt für mich:
Spiegel,
ganz zum Schluss erst das Waschbecken,
hier noch die Oberflächen,
die Fenster.
Das mache ich eben mal schnell.
Und
ja,
dann haben wir es bald,
bald geschafft.
Die Badewanne ist bei uns nicht jeden Tag im Einsatz.
Daher ist sie auch nicht wirklich verkalkt.
Denn nach der Benutzung reibe ich sie immer gleich aus.
Aber, was natürlich bei der Badewanne passiert,
sie staubt schnell ein.
Das heißt, die kann ich dann auch einmal kurz ausreiben.
Das mache ich so einmal die Woche ungefähr.
Jeden Tag muss ich das auch nicht machen.
Und dann ist die Badewanne auch schön sauber.
Und wenn sie doch verkalkt ist,
dann auch wie bei der Dusche
einfach etwas Zitronensäure verwenden
und alle verkalkten Stellen sauber machen.
Hier an den Fenstern haben wir Plissees dran
einfach als Sichtschutz,
dass von drüben keiner reingucken kann.
Die reinige ich jetzt einfach so,
nehme einen Staubwedel.
Ein feuchtes Tuch geht aber auch.
Ich meine, unsere sind jetzt nicht schmutzig.
Die sind jetzt nur ein bisschen staubig.
Das war es schon.
Dann kann ich jetzt hier schön
von innen und außen die Fenster putzen,
erst mal die Rahmen,
dann die Fenster innen und dann eben außen.
[Musik]
Ich muss zugeben,
seit dem letzten Frühjahr
haben wir hier das Fenster nicht mehr geputzt, glaube ich.
So sieht es nämlich aus.
Aber man sieht es halt nicht. Die Plissees sind davor.
Okay.
Hier innen muss ich jetzt
dämpfen. Das sieht katastrophal aus!
[Musik]
Fertig!
Jetzt noch alle übrigen Oberflächen wischen.
[Musik]
Ach komm, Josh. Putzen macht schon glücklich, oder?
>> JOSH: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Gell?
So.
Machen wir eine kurze Pause
und dann geht es an die Waschbecken
und an den Boden.
Und dann bin ich fertig.
Gestärkt vom Mittagessen geht es jetzt weiter.
Ich werde jetzt hier noch,
alles, was hier staubig ist, abstauben,
das heißt die Leisten, die Steckdosen,
hier bei uns wäre es noch diese Wand.
Geht jetzt auch ganz fix.
[Musik]
Dann bin ich jetzt hier am Waschbecken.
Da nehme ich jetzt wieder meine Natron-Essig-Mischung.
Einmal für den Abfluss
und auch
hier für den Kalk
richtig schön Zitronensäure.
Und da mache ich es jetzt so:
Ich habe hier noch mal Wasser aufgekocht.
Der Wasserkocher muss sowieso
auch gerade entkalkt werden.
Das heißt, hier gebe ich jetzt reine Zitronensäure rein.
So kann ich den Wasserkocher entkalken
und mit dem Zitronenwasser
oder Zitronensäurewasser
dann eben hier noch schön alles sauber bekommen.
[Musik]
Bei starken Verkalkungen und Verschmutzungen
könnt ihr jetzt wieder Zitronensäure nehmen,
hier an den Rand geben, kurz einwirken lassen
und dann wegspülen.
[Musik]
In dem Becher haben wir unsere Zahnbürsten drin.
Und den muss ich natürlich
auch immer wieder im Alltag ausspülen.
Ansonsten hat man da unten ganz viel Schmiere drin.
Hier gebe ich jetzt auch das Zitronensäurewasser rein.
Und dann stelle ich da auch gleich unsere Zahnbürsten rein.
Denn die sind ja auch gerne mal verunreinigt.
Die Köpfe, die wechsel ich jetzt sowieso.
Die kommen gleich weg.
Und gerade hier
kann man das schön mal hier reintauchen
und dann schön sauber machen.
[Musik]
Noch alle anderen Teile, die gerne mal verkalken,
könnt ihr mit dem Zitronensäurewasser sauber bekommen.
[Musik]
Die vorletzte Tätigkeit ist jetzt das Saugen.
Immer schön von hinten nach vorne,
also vom hinteren Raum in den vorderen.
[Musik]
Jetzt bin ich am Ziel angekommen.
Der letzte Schritt ist jetzt Boden wischen.
Meistens nehme ich im Alltag dafür
einfach etwas Schmierseife.
Da könnt ihr euch gerne in meinem Reinigervideo anschauen,
wie ich meinen Bodenreiniger zusammenmische.
Jetzt, weil ich wirklich gerade viele Verschmutzungen habe,
nehme ich den Dampfreiniger,
damit alles wieder schön sauber und rein ist.
Und danach gibt es noch ein paar Tipps und Tricks,
wie euer Bad auch im Alltag richtig schön sauber bleibt.
[Musik]
Frühjahrsputz im Bad ist bald fertig!
Den Mülleimer habe ich jetzt auch schon sauber gemacht.
Und, damit der immer gut riecht,
nehmt ihr einfach auch Orangenöl,
gebt es auf etwas Toilettenpapier
und das lege ich jetzt hier direkt unten in den Eimer rein.
Und dann riecht es immer lecker nach Orange,
wenn sich der Eimer öffnet.
Hier kommt jetzt wieder mein Kosmetikeimerbeutel rein.
Und die restlichen Beutel,
die kommen auch einfach hier unten mit rein.
So habt ihr immer eine Tüte direkt im Anschluss da,
wenn der volle Müllbeutel weggebracht wird.
Menschen mit langen Haaren werden wissen,
wovon ich jetzt spreche.
Wenn ich hier dusche
und meine Haare shampooniere,
wasche ich sie aus.
Danach kommt noch ein bisschen Spülung rein oder Haarkur.
Und dann kommt es oft vor,
dass meine Haare einfach ziemlich ausfallen.
Und, bevor ich sie dann hier unten einfach
in den Abfluss fließen lasse,
sammel ich sie.
Also ich kämme meine Haare
immer so ein bisschen mit den Fingern durch.
Ich sammel die Haare, knote sie zusammen,
lege sie dann an den Rand
und schmeiße sie dann eben nach der Dusche
einfach in den Mülleimer.
So verstopft der Abfluss nicht so schnell
und man spart sich eben auch enorm viel Zeit.
Und das kann man wirklich täglich
bei der Dusche einfach beachten.
Am Waschbecken und in der Dusche
habe ich immer ein Mikrofasertuch liegen.
So kann ich jeden Tag nach dem Zähneputzen,
nach dem Händewaschen
einfach kurz drüberreiben.
So könnt ihr im Alltag nämlich
wirklich alles schön sauber halten.
Entweder legt ihr es direkt dazu
oder ihr versteckt es so ein bisschen,
wenn das Tuch nicht ganz so schön ist.
Und am besten ist es aber wirklich,
wenn ihr könnt,
baut euch eine BWT Anlage ein,
also eine Enthärtungsanlage.
So habt ihr schon von Grund auf kalkfreieres Wasser
und es entstehen erst gar nicht so viele Kalkflecken.
[Musik]
Abends oder morgens nach dem Zähneputzen
nutze ich übrigens auch gerne mal die Zeit,
um auszumisten und Dinge wegzuräumen,
die hier nicht rein gehören.
Also, wenn ihr sowieso gerade nur rumsteht
und Zähne putzt und euch im Bad bewegt,
dann räumt einfach schon mal alles weg,
alle Kleider, die ihr nicht mehr braucht.
Lasst nichts herumliegen.
Und dann bleibt euer Bad auch im Alltag immer schön sauber.
Also ich würde sagen, im Alltag
putze ich wirklich schon relativ viel
so, während ich mich fertig mache.
Und wenn ich dann meinen wöchentlichen Badputz mache,
brauche ich ungefähr eine Dreiviertelstunde bis Stunde.
Die Fenster habe ich ja jetzt nicht jedes Mal dabei
oder auch die Fliesen an der Wand.
Von daher geht das wirklich superschnell.
Ich hoffe, euch hat dieses Video gefallen.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Du gehst jetzt auch dein Bad putzen, hä?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
>> SAMIRA: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Und Mama hat jetzt
Feierabend!
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Ah.
Tschüss!
[Musik]